la coupe du monde de football 2022 une
grand messe sportive brassant des
milliards d'euros est accueilli dans
l'un des bastions mondiaux de l'
esclavage moderne le qatar c'est ce que
dénonce amnesty international dans un
rapport publié il ya quelques jours lo
ng note bien une amélioration dans la
législation relative aux droits humains
mais en pratique le qatar est encore
loin de tenir ses engagements en terme
de respect du droit des travailleurs
immigrés au nombre de 2 millions dans le
pays l'autosatisfaction manifeste des
autorités a exposé des milliers de
personnes à un risque persistant
d'exploitation par des employeurs peu
scrupuleux dans des situations où
beaucoup d'entre elles ne sont pas en
mesure de changer d'emploi et sont
victimes de pratiques s'apparentant à un
vol de salaire en cause la kafala cette
pratique de parrainage qui a cours dans
les pays du golfe persique
tout étranger qui souhaite travailler au
qatar doit passer par les fourches
caudines d'un cas fils un sponsor local
qui a tout pouvoir sur l'employé et a
notamment pour habitude de lui
confisquer son passeport avec les
dérives que l'on imagine malgré les
réformes adoptées par doha certains
éléments problématiques du système de
kafala reste en place cela inclut la
possibilité pour des employeurs abusifs
de s'opposer à ce que les travailleurs
migrants change de travail et de
contrôler leur statut juridique d'autres
dérives inclut le non versement de
salaires et le refus d'octroyer certains
avantages afin qu'il soit plus difficile
pour les travailleurs et travailleuses
de quitter leur emploi les migrants
immigrantes continue à dépendre de leur
employeur pour entrer au qatar et y
rester ce qui donne lieu à des tactiques
auquel les employeurs abusifs recours
afin de contrôler leur main d'oeuvre
privés de leurs droits un grand nombre
de travailleurs immigrés majoritairement
issus d'asie travail en conséquence dans
les pires conditions imaginables
et cela vaut pour les forçats des
chantiers de la coupe du monde selon
l'organisation internationale du travail
cinquante travailleurs immigrés sont
décédées au qatar l'an dernier et un
demi millier d'autres ont été grièvement
c'est majoritairement dans le secteur de
la construction selon une enquête du
guardian paru en février dernier plus de
6500 travailleurs indiens un népalais ou
bangladais ont trouvé la mort depuis
2010 au qatar un chiffre qui pourrait
être sous-évalué les décès sont pour la
plupart survenus sur les nombreux
chantiers des routes autoroutes
aéroports hôtels et bien sûr des stades
le tout lié à l'organisation du mondial
les résultats révèle l'incapacité du
qatar a protégé sa main-d'oeuvre
migrante forte de deux millions de
personnes ou même à enquêter sur les
causes du taux apparemment élevé de
décès parmi ces travailleurs pour la
plupart jeunes face à ce drame humain
certaines voix du monde du foot se sont
élevées surtout en provenance des pays
nordiques comme le danemark seule équipe
scandinave qualifier au mondial la
fédération danoise a prévu de remplacer
sur le maillot des joueurs les habituels
logos des sponsors par des messages sur
les droits de l'homme cela dit pour le
moment rien ne compromet réellement la
tenue du mondial au qatar pas plus que
n'en avait été bouleversée celle de 1978
organisée par la junte argentine du
général videla alors au pouvoir pour son
plus grand bénéfice mais cette fois au
delà du contexte politique c'est
l'organisation même de l'épreuve qui est
sujette à caution son attribution fait
toujours l'objet d'une enquête pour
corruption active et passive recel et
blanchiment on entend souvent que le
sport n'a rien à voir avec la politique
rarement une phrase n'a été aussi
impropre